oh look at that I like that guys if
you're looking for some scary books to
read this Halloween season we got you
this morning we're highlighting some
that are sure to get you in the spirit
so to speak Amazon books editorial
director Sarah gellman joins us hey
Sarah good to see you as always listen
you you say all the books are different
levels of spooky they're different scary
I am a total wimp so these are not like
the good books they're more like tingles
um yes but you're starting with a
monster a monster story this is probably
the scariest one at least for me so this
book is called malice house by Megan
Shepard and it it is a monster story so
it's about a young woman who inherits
her father's house and he was a Pulitzer
prize-winning writer and she discovers a
manuscript in the house that's unlike
anything he's ever written it's called
bedtime stories for Monsters and she
starts illustrating the book and the
Monsters become very real to her we'll
say that a wink okay um and again like
it's scary but so fun it was I was
scared in a fun scary but fun yeah uh
next up you got a thriller with some
indigenous folk magic what is that yes I
love this book river woman River demon
by Jennifer Gabon nice title it's unlike
anything I've ever read before because
the author actually she's taking a genre
that I think a lot of us are familiar
with a thriller psychological domestic
Thriller and then she's adding in
elements from her own culture indigenous
and Mexican-American so it sprinkled
with folk magic and I'll love this so
much I actually picked it for my book
club on Amazon Sarah selects as our
October pick all right and the premise
is there's this Chicana artist Eva
Santos Moon and her life is ripped apart
when her husband is accused of brutally
murdering their mutual friend and his
business partner oh man and she cannot
remember anything from that night so
she's trying to piece together what
actually happened and she's being
fluented by the ghost of the woman that
has been murdered and also a woman from
her past okay Sarah so I'm the type of
person I like my scary stories to be
real so you have some non-fiction I got
a book for you yes all the living and
the dead it's by Haley Campbell so this
is a book that is
it's basically about people that make
death their their life's work so it's
about executioners and balmers
um and it's perfect for people who like
True Crime podcasts or anyone like you
that likes their horror kind of
documentary yeah yeah yeah and the
author takes this question of if we
don't know that much about death why are
we so afraid of it yeah and we are
afraid of it and it's going to happen to
all of us yes exactly the difference
you've got yeah you've got a picture
book recommendation that your son helped
you with yes I let I let my own little
critics pick this out this is the little
ghost that lost her boo and it's
basically it's about a ghost who wakes
up and she loses her boo her mom tells
her that her scaring days are over but
the little ghost sets out and she's
gonna find it and it has that I like
that sometimes it has this really cute
interactive ending that my boys think is
hilarious I like that I like that a lot
teens and adults you call a thriller too
yes it's creep a love story at Ligia day
at Pena floor this is if you take the
show you and you cross it with Fatal
Attraction but make it for teens this is
what Crete reminds me of it's a high
school student who gets obsessed with
the most popular couple in high school
and it's good for adults I read it super
fun and it's like it's a inhale in one
sitting kind of read we all remember the
most popular couple in high school yeah
I have to look at those guys I'm
stealing this for a little teddy here I
love it yeah the ghost can't say boo and
the owl says would you like to borrow my
who yeah
I love that I love it there we go but
thank you very much appreciate it